hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
nintendogs zwei kurze sachen erst mal
ich bin total krank und muss aber
irgendwie videos vorproduzieren von
urlaub wenn ihr das video gesehen bin
ich im urlaub und ich bin krank deswegen
habe ich meine stimme ein bisschen
minute an und ich habe mein schreibtisch
stuhl des establishment aber nur falls
ihr euch fragt wieso da jetzt was
anderes hinter mir ist
wir fangen ja same nintendogs weil nun
möchte ich mal wieder schön gestreichelt
werden schön im gesicht natürlich und
ich würde sagen wir jeder kann man runde
gastiert war louvo wir dann in die hunde
halle gehen werden oder wie das halt die
hunde heimische mitgenommen dann gehe
ich jetzt auf dem rückweg einfach mal
hier lang und wieder zog nach hause ja
die route ist in ordnung ich hoffe immer
noch dass ball einfach mal irgendwann
irgendwas krasses geiles findet wo wir
dann sagen können das könnte für 400
euro verkauft und dann kaufen uns
einfach mal neun hund und wir haben eine
flasche
freu dich doch nicht so dieses fleisch
hat mal wieder überhaupt keinen wert das
ist supertoll das ist sehr geil dass wir
ich bin traurig stimmt
immer wenn ich hochredet zum hals da
kann man für den hindernisparcours
trainieren um dann
hüpft doch gut kommen weil du schaffst
du musst ich weiß nicht aber hier drin
ist ja echt gut ich hatte voll bock
darauf irgendwas einen
hindernis-parcours wettbewerb dann mal
mitzumachen hier noch schnell drüber
springen balu und fehler wenn du bist
super du schaffst es echt also
fehler das ist nämlich auch die sache
wenn mich jetzt nämlich den
hindernisparcours gewinn dann können wir
vielleicht heute schon neue hunde kaufen
stellt euch das mal vor das war super
ich finde es auch immer geil was
nintendo schöne grafik aufweisen kann
also ich habe wirklich nie
viele meinen ja voll und 4 soll die
geile grafik haben viele meinen das neue
call of duty soll eine geile grafik aber
wenn ich mir diese leute da vorne
anschaue
nichts kann irgendwas gegen den tender
ochs war läuft wie so eine ratte
das macht ja viele meinen dass nintendos
auf dauer so ein bisschen langweilig
wird und dass man da nicht unbedingt und
komplettes
es war klar dass man da halt kein kommt
es war einfach auch klar viele mein halt
ist es eher so ein kurzfristiges
projektes
pro alter den katheter ich hätte dir so
aufs maul gehauen
warum viele meiner sei es ein
kurzfristiges projekt und das wird auf
dauer langweilig aber ich finde es so
eine sache weil es mir selber
unglaublich viel spaß macht und auch
jetzt gerade wieder wer diese
hindernisparcours dich so voll das ist
doch damals dann trinkt noch mal vorher
schön ein bisschen damit du gleich
komplett fit bist beim wettkampf und
dann gehen wir jetzt nämlich mal zum
hindernisparcours nintendo kam
anfängerklasse hindernis-parcours hallo
und willkommen zur anfängerklasse im
hindernisparcours schon traurig dass wir
nach so vielen folgen der anfängerklasse
sind weil du was willst du sagen wir
schaffen das
scheiße mit fünf punkten und einer zeit
von 28 liegt schäferhund trixi von
adonis im flug wer nennt sich adonis ja
ok ich hab' ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt
irgendwie ein gutes gefühl dabei wir
hatten bisher immer nur pech aber ich
glaube jetzt schaffen wir wirklich
springt rüber waren kurz leiden lässt
und punkte verspielt war ein dummkopf
trainierten einspringt morgen springt
was wissen sie auf dem dritten platz mit
abzügen von 15 punkte in einer zeit von
blau de
was macht man mit dem toll gemacht ich
habe gerade erfahren dass sich 30 euro
preisgeld bekommen habe das reicht
vielleicht nicht für rund sondern für
einen hundekörbchen wir haben 439 euro
ich muss mal ganz kurz schauen ob jetzt
irgendwo auch dann nicht hundepension
ich dummkopf gibt es schon hunde die
irgendwie so um den dreh kosten sondern
labrador oder so der kostet schaut euch
an wie hässlich diese hunde sind
trotzdem die schlimm ja dann hat es
heute leider nicht geklappt dass wir uns
doch nun gekauft haben nächstes mal
würde ich dann nochmal genau den
gleichen ablauf machen also in denen
hunde halle shit und danach würden wir
damit quasi versuchen noch mal so ein
wettkampf zu machen und danach dann
kaufen bei ihren kleinen spielkameraden
balu wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würden wir alle und ich uns über eine
bewertung freuen und schreibt mir die
kommentare was man meinen blogs noch
machen könnte wo ihre auf drauf